djebbour qui est contre la science et le
dit
la séance est levée passé on se devait
placer josiane cours d'un goûter puis
tous les républicains de la 2e
circonscription de saône et loire
vous êtes ici au coeur de ma
circonscription circonscription avec un
élevage bovin mais également aux vins et
nous avons aujourd'hui une vraie
problématique avec l'arrivée du loup sur
ce territoire depuis la première attaque
je suis aux côtés des éleveurs pour
essayer de trouver les meilleures
solutions
un paysage de bocage paisible pas de
grandes étendues sauvages pas de haute
montagne
pourtant la circonscription de josiane
corneloup est devenu le territoire d'un
prédateur redoutable un loup solitaire
vient d'attaquer ici à 32 reprises sur
12 communes 122 brebis tuées entre juin
et octobre
le lou s'est invité dans le charolais et
s'y sent chez lui c'est un excellent
terrain de chasse pour le loup parce
qu'on
énormément de m nous avons énormément de
muret énormément de forêts et des forêts
extrêmement basses donc il peut se
cacher un loisir enfants le loup le
voici capter de nuit par un piège
photographique les spécialistes le
qualifie de loups d'evian la plupart du
temps il égorge les brebis sans les
manger un comportement anormal
ces attaques particulièrement violentes
sont devenus le cauchemar des éleveurs
je vais vous montrer le deux semaines
plus tôt denis berland a perdu 6 brebis
en une seule attaque un traumatisme
j'ai découvert une brebis dans le milieu
de la prairie qui était qui étaient
mortes plus loin cinq brebis qui était
qui était dans un coin de près donc là
je me suis s'est passé quelque chose et
j'ai contourné la prairie pour voir un
peu plus haut il y en avait 3 4 des
tanins et puis après j'ai découvert que
même si j'ai ma deuxième fille il m'est
tombé dans les bras et en pleurs et
qu'il m'a dit papa comment on va faire
avec les brebis ça prend aux tripes
quand même où il avait senti venir si
j'ai senti venir parce que donc la
première attaque était juste au dessus
d'un kilomètre n'aime pas et ça faisait
depuis le début que je tournais
surveiller mais mes brebis toutes les
nuits quoi tes nuits je me levais pour y
faire un tour dans les dents les autres
mais en fait vous faites un tour mais
peut passer un quart d'heure après six
ans
le loup attaque surtout la nuit face à
la menace l'éleveur est contraint de
rentrer ses brebis jusqu'au matin une
pratique inhabituelle à ce moment de
l'année
sendra ce qu'elle veut à l'herbe eux
essentiellement l'herbe il faut que
cette race c'est soit auprès c'est
indéniable elles n'ont pas l'aspect
fraîche comme comme elle devrait être à
l'herbe
on le voit le sont grises à son blanche
de tête alors qu'elle devrait être rouge
et fraîche de l'année j'allais voir
comment ils vont être heureuse de sortir
cours
ok parce que on se dit la prochaine
attaque elle sera ou quoi le peut être
la tête à côté c'est imprévisible
imprévisible vous voyez bien le bocage
charolais là c'est pas défendable voyez
bien on va pas mettre de la clôture
électrifiée tout partout c'est
impossible impossible il ya eu une
attaque en face à une attaque juste
derrière le bois le bois qu'on voit au
fond loulay là au milieu là aujourd'hui
il est là où on sait pas comment ça
m'obsédait oui parce que derrière tout
ça il ya une famille aussi
les enfants ils mangent du loup matin
midi soir et c'est pas d'essai pour des
sujets qu'on devrait avoir avec des
enfants
ces brebis sont victimes du plan loup
un dispositif mis en place en 2018 par
nicolas hulot alors ministre de la
transition écologique
il fait de ce prédateur une espèce
protégée qui ne peut être traqués que de
façon exceptionnelle les éleveurs ont du
mal à comprendre on en train de nous
dire au niveau national qu'il faut
rentrer nos nous tous rentrés en
bergerie pour les protéger du loup c'est
parce qu'il faut faire faut tuer le loup
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
même si on nous dit qu aujourd'hui il
est possible de vivre avec nous dans nos
territoires et qu'il faut s'adapter
je pense que ça n'est pas possible dès
la première attaque
josiane corps de luz et placer du côté
des éleveurs et la semaine précédente
elle a même décroché pour eux une belle
victoire
c'était lors des questions au
gouvernement la balle est à madame
josiane corneloup merci monsieur le
président ce n'est pas aux éleveurs de
modifier leur façon de travailler et de
s'adapter aux comportements des loups
pas plus qu'ils n'ont à construire des
bunkers pour abriter leurs moutons au
nom d'une biodiversité y réfléchit
imposées par l'état allez vous
reconsidérer les dispositions du plan
loup pour que celui ci prenne enfin en
compte les intérêts des éleveurs et
assure la pérennité d'une économie
pastorale à laquelle vous comme moi
sommes très attachés
je vous remercie sûr que la barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique sur la question du loup
n'oublions pas que c'est une espèce
protégée et qui doit le rester
c'est une espèce protégée mon rôle en
tant que ministre de la transition
écologique c'est de faire en sorte que
cette coexistence puisse se passer le
mieux possible sur la situation
particulière dont vous parlez sur la
saône et loire
l'ensemble des mesures d'effarouchement
qui n'ont pas été suffisantes nous ont
amenés à décider et le préfet
coordinateur l'a annoncé a autorisé un
tir de prélèvement pour ce loup
la députée vient d'obtenir ce qu'elle
voulait le tir de prélèvement c'est une
précaution de langage pour signifier
l'abattage d'une une autorisation
rarissime qui peut être accordé que cinq
fois par an en france
mais le plus dur commence la traque tout
le monde ne peut pas attirer la bête
christian mazuray et lieux de nantes
d'une institution vieille de charlemagne
la louveterie de france
c'est à lui et 15 autres bénévoles
louvetiers que la préfecture a confié la
lourde tâche de tuer le nous au total le
dispositif compte une cinquantaine de
volontaires tous formés et équipés les
vues de près alors qu'on te fois on l'a
vu quelquefois la caméra thermique
caméra thermique c'est cet engin avec
nous permet de voir la nuit toutes les
formes qui dégagent une chaleur d'hier
un humain animal on arrive à les
détecter
mais christian mas zoomer et surtout
rodez à la traque du renard ou du
sanglier des loups il n'en a encore
jamais vu il sait que même à 50 contre 1
le combat est loin d'être gagné
il a face à lui un animal hors norme
je pense que plusieurs fois il nous a
détecté nous a senti nous a vus et que
nous la formule donc cet animal c'est
quand même un animal très intelligent je
dirais c'est à dire que c'est sale
animal qui qui va prendre des décisions
rapides et qui va se scinda pts et
situation mais j'ai l'impression votre
mission elle est terrible parce qu'en
fait vous avez un espace immense il faut
chercher un loup on sait pas du tout me
va être
un espace immense mais que la préfecture
a voulu délimiter les louvetiers ne
peuvent intervenir que dans un périmètre
de 37 communes sauf que le lou va
contourner allègrement ce dispositif le
voilà qui frappe à champlecy juste en
dehors du périmètre de chasse bernard
bonneau vient de perdre trois bêtes ce
n'est pas le moment de lui parler du
plan loup et de la préfecture
je pensais danse à côté du rhin
et puis pourquoi jean blaise il était
pendant le tir du prélèvement que
pourquoi pourquoi on nous pond une
espèce de cartes qui ressemblait à rien
du tout oula
ces fameux fédérons m'ont dit on a tracé
tout droit mais si c'est n'importe quoi
moi j'ai l'immense île par le poids de
champlecy c'est qu'ils sont sûrs d'eux
mais ces gens là sont sûrs de rien du
tout mais rien du tout ici bleus rien du
tout quoi
le tir de prélèvement est autorisé pour
15 jours au-delà de ces quinze jours ce
tir de prélèvement pourra être prorogée
pour 15 jours supplémentaires
mais on pourra re définir le périmètre
et pourquoi pas remettre le département
pour toi pour mettre le département je
vois ça s'annule quoi de faire une carte
comme ça c'est pas parce que loulou on
va mettre x plessis il va s'attaquer à
relève quoi il va à volesvres quand ces
cas là on recommence on réétudie on perd
le sommeil quoi c c'est énervant puis on
est prêt à tout faire quand même hein on
était très gentil jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais la tension monte madame corps ne
nous faites attention la tension monte
il va se faire des conneries quoi pour
les éleveurs
reste une solution se défendre tout seul
étienne debarnot est un éleveur
chasseurs ces bêtes aussi ont été
attaqués alors cet été il a suivi une
courte formation sur le loup 2h30
d'enseignements théoriques
cela lui donne le droit de tuer le
prédateur mais seulement s'il s'attaque
à son troupeau
cela s'appelle le tir de défense
alors chaque soir à la tombée de la nuit
il sort le fuit
on a l'information on commence de
s'équiper après c'est pareil ses
discussions avec les louvetiers et la
brigade du loup ils ont des petits
indices pour nous aider à comprendre ou
à s'adapter comme là on va les voir j'ai
fait un petit affluent de fortune pour
me placer pour me cacher justement pour
couper le coupé le goût un petit peu
vous pas restée plantée on va les voir
ah oui parce que vous vous cachez
derrière et donc en fait ça masque un
peu les odeurs de l'humain fabre à
closer humain avec sa torche et son
fusil de courte portée
le jeune chasseur sait que ses chances
de tirer la bête sont infimes mais il ne
se décourage pas la lampe est là donc là
je me suis fait un emplacement ici parce
que j'ai la vue sur mes brebis là bas
donc encore faut-il que vous sachiez qui
passent par là qu'ils soient là eh ben
c'est le prix que je me suis fait
attaquer donc il est potentiellement
dans sa tête est déjà venu déjà venu là
donc il connaît d'accord moi je trouve
que effectivement c'est quand même très
aléatoire il faut beaucoup de chance
pour tuer parce que quand on voit les
distance qu'ils parcourent et quand on
voit la difficulté à le repérer déjà sur
tout ça voilà vous n'allez pas passer au
poste comme ceux ci dans les champs tous
les soirs ça prévient la saône et loire
n'est pas prête à cohabiter avec le loup
la députée on a ce soir plus que jamais
la conviction le protocole que nous
suivons aujourd'hui le plan national
nous c'était un protocole qui était mise
en oeuvre pour l'arc alpin qui n'était
d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises
c'est un phénomène nouveau et nous le
traitons que parce qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui
peut-être faut-il imaginer autre chose
pour ces zones d'élevage bon ben je
souhaite bon courage
c'est mon poste alors c'est vrai que ce
qui serait peut-être le plus intéressant
pour vous c'est d'un match ce soir je
suis
à bientôt
la députée repart etienne debarnot lui
reste là comme toutes les nuits il
passera plusieurs heures à guetter un
superprédateur aussi insaisissable que
mystérieux
[Musique]